estamos viendo una obra de françois
bücher se llama madame de pompadour y
esta pintura es del rococó tiene algo
tiene algo especial que me encanta me
gusta bastante tiene algo muy bello
simplemente tiene tiene algo que me
seduce y son las rosas los colores rosas
en su pulsera los listones y la brocha
con la que aplica maquillaje se puso ese
algodón las flores el rosa de sus
cachetes la hacen ver muy coqueta las
flores azules de su cabellera es
encantadora y el rosa en la punta de la
brocha con la que aplica maquillaje
parece algodón de azúcar es simplemente
apetitoso hablemos un poco sobre esto
porque porque son cosas que captan el
ojo fácilmente los listones rosas tienen
una cualidad arquitectónica parece
parecen son extraordinarios tienen
volumen y estructura y puedes sentir el
peso y la textura de la tela mientras
que la esponja la esponja blanca es
totalmente lo opuesto también podemos
ver aquí el enfoque en la pulsera es un
retrato de el rey luis de francia pero
observa observa el contraste de la
pulsera con la figura de su cara la cual
es muy suave y muy cálida
observa el tamaño de sus ojos en
comparación con su boca la han hecho ver
como una niña la han hecho ver con una
niña parece parece como estar viendo uno
de esos dibujos japoneses
esos dibujos anime entonces claro que
esto no tiene no tiene que ver con su
personalidad para nada su personalidad
su humanidad esto es lo que para mí
es de lo que habla la pintura ella y lo
que lo que representa la corte francesa
en las pinturas rococó esto se trata
sobre la vestimenta el maquillaje es
simplemente superficialidad aunque esto
parece inclinarse más a lo último porque
ella ella es la amante del rey la
proximidad entre ellos ellos estaban
juntos parece como si si fuera su mejor
amiga y le quiere compartir un secreto
íntimo su mirada vemos que su mirada se
alza vemos esta línea el retrato de su
amado su pecho el listón de su cuello
hasta que por fin llegamos a su rostro
parece remoto lo primero que yo note es
este exceso de accesorios después veo su
cara y yo pienso ella es la amante del
rey pero me pregunto quién es ella quién
es esta mujer veo su cara para encontrar
pistas y no encuentro también veo el
sentido de claridad con la que fue
pintada pero que va en contra de la
suavidad y la indeterminación de su
individualidad es yo creo representado
lo veo representado en el cuello el
cuello y los artefactos ahí son duros
son tiesos y casi de alguna manera
congelados fríos pero luego veo su
suavidad entonces me hace pensar que
existe una indeterminación y misterio en
esta obra de françois boucher